a down year for aaron rodgers yeah for
most quarterbacks and i love it when
people say the quiet thing out loud and
uh
you know you you you were a little down
on him last year maybe that was a
message for you
maybe he knows maybe he knows that you
you detected some slippage in his game
last year oh listen if that's what it
takes to motivate my favorite
quarterback then so be it let's go buddy
all right i mean but he's he's on his
game you know i think aaron rodgers
first off he is right i mean come on i
mean what we talk about i think the
analytics were world you know that got
involved in some of the conversations
last year
people looked at it like that and you
know the
the mahomes and stats factors green bay
running the ball balance yeah it's only
26 touchdowns and it's you know it's not
close to 5 000 yards like some of the
other top-tier quarterbacks and i think
people look at that too
but you know the reality is is the guy
is still doing more with less than just
about anybody in football i mean he's
he's the title holder as that is
concerned more with less that should be
on his gravestone i gave you more with
less i so much so that years we were i
was the quarterback of a team that
really wasn't even a playoff contender
and people were picking this to go to
the super bowl because i was the
quarterback and i think right now
he's just gotten to a point where i've
always
one of the reasons i like him is because
he's honest and kind of does stuff like
that every now and then where he just
says it but i think like he gives zero
f's right now in 2020 after the packers
drafted jordan love and people are
questioning him and i think he's finally
hit that point of his career where he's
like i mean what i don't get it what
more do i gotta do so i guess if these
people aren't gonna like me then the
hell with it they're never gonna like me
and i might as well just say what's on
my mind and go that way so uh i i've
always respected that about aaron
rodgers how open he is that way
i like the more with less on the
gravestone and it got me wondering what
what do you want on your gravestone
i don't know
i don't know
i haven't thought about it that deeply
yet i don't know put a pin in it
all right
self self scout thyself pete demolition
there's lots of things uh that we can
put on there so i gotta narrow it down a
little bit
uh but aaron rodgers really is having an
incredible year and last year he had an
incredible you had 4 000 passing yards
26 touchdowns and four interceptions
and and he's even better this year and
you know my theory on aaron rodgers
and the manipulation of aaron rodgers
personality potentially by packers ceo
mark murphy it goes back to last year
the aftermath of the tyler dunn bleacher
report article that was very unfavorable
of both mike mccarthy the former packers
head coach and aaron rodgers and rogers
was salty about it and mark murphy at
some point after the fact had a quote
along the lines of well if this upsets
some people maybe it's a good thing
and i can't help but wonder whether to
what extent there was a little bit of
mad scientist going on when they drafted
jordan love
to get that same impact
to get that same effect and on one hand
we're protected we have a guy we can
develop for the future that we like and
jordan love and on the other hand if it
pisses off aaron rodgers and he reaches
a level of performance that we may be
concerned he's not able to continue to
reach even better yeah and if if that's
the case you know mark murphy
technically wouldn't qualify for
executive of the year because he's not
the gm
but
i i tell you what i got to give him
credit for two years in a row it's quite
possible he's found a way to apply that
red-hot poker to aaron rodgers and get
even more out of him than maybe he
otherwise would have gotten well yeah
maybe maybe i don't i still don't know
if i necessarily care or agree i think
aaron rodgers was going to still be the
same aaron rodgers we see right now
regardless he he's he's building a
legacy this guy wants to be the greatest
of all time so i mean i get you did this
maybe motivated he's win more super
bowls right now he does he he does i get
that you know but i don't know if
that'll happen you know here we are
again i mean you know look at what he's
doing look at the group around him at
receiver and yeah maybe green bay was
smart and realized yeah they're a little
more talented than maybe you and i
thought but still
i mean
do we want to go back to the draft i
mean there still was receivers on the
board or trade up i sure i sure wouldn't
have been mad if they traded up a few
more spots and got justin jefferson
instead of your vikings or maybe got you
know a brandon iuke or or some of the
other the the t higgins that the bengals
took in the first pick of the second
round and some of the other receivers
that go in the second round that are
very talented you know they could use
them certainly and then and again we see
their defense is not great either so
it's just rogers is magical that way
that is why he'll go down as the
greatest of all time for me just in his
prime i never saw anybody do
more with less or more with more when he
did have more like in 2010 and 11 and
you know 12 when they had talent at
receiver and things like that so
uh we'll see where this goes but they
got a good thing going right now i do
know that um and and everybody's
noticing what aaron rodgers is doing on
the field
easy way to bring to life what you're
saying just consider
what the past decade would have been for
tom brady if he was the quarterback of
the green bay packers and all of the
things were equal that's you know yes
i i just think again it's it's a thing
that goes
you know unnoticed or sometimes not
talked about hey we you and i
sit here and we
we're like amazed we marvel at patrick
mahomes every week right
and sometimes i gotta remind myself and
go well damn he does have travis kelsey
tyree kill sammy watkins andy reed clyde
edwards hilaire like one of the five
best pass protecting the lines in
football so you know two
you can never see the all greatness of a
player until you can get the support
system around him that can really like
accentuate all the things the player can
do great and to me there was years there
where yeah we lost that with rogers
because he just had to make it happen
himself the offense couldn't contribute
to his greatness and that's why we'll
see you know an underwhelming playoff
career resume or maybe only one super
bowl win you know but but that too is
another conversation itself it just that
i think in itself sometimes tells you
how special aaron rodgers is because a
lot of people start with that right away
he's only won one super bowl and all
that and i just i always go like but you
never hear that the first thing out of
the drew brees conversation nobody goes
he only won one super bowl we know
because he was a really awesome player a
part of a you know a machine that was
great and he had an offense that was
great and the support system aaron
rodgers
everybody sees the talent they just you
know if you're not following football or
no scheme or things like that you just
think man what's going on why can't they
win the big game is it his leadership or
what and i would go no it's that fourth
grade offense he was involved in for a
number of years in his career that
couldn't help him out to really show all
the greatness he had
you made a comment earlier about aaron
rodgers being driven to be regarded as
the greatest of all time and you know it
made me think about the quarterbacks out
there who are pursuing legacies yeah and
and just think about the nfc setting
aside patrol homes lamar jackson any
other quarterbacks there ben
roethlisberger is desperate to get
another super bowl win or two he's
spoken in terms of multiple
you've got aaron rodgers yeah who knows
that one isn't enough right russell
wilson who knows that one isn't enough
right and tom brady who still believes
that six
aren't enough right all in the same
conference and john breeze for
yeah and all all jockeying for the right
to play for that one with no guarantee
they're gonna win it because they're
gonna have to go against the chiefs or
the ravens or some other great team from
the afc right it it
you know it's it's such an elusive thing
to get that super bowl there's only one
trophy given out per year
so somebody's not going to build the
legacy that he wants to build at the end
of the day we're going to have to write
that story with one or zero super bowl
championships and it makes what brady
has accomplished with the patriots even
more amazing the fact that he hogged
them all in this two decades where
there's been a lot of great quarterbacks
that's right and he's hogged six of them
right and i look at this current group
and i project forward like how like how
many will lamar jackson have how many
wilma homes have how many will your boy
blue josh allen have yeah right there's
only one every year and we're going to
have great quarterbacks who just spin
their wheels for their whole careers
because there's only going to be one to
go around every year it really is
fascinating yeah because we're seeing
some all-time great quarterbacks right
who aren't going to have the hardware to
back it up you're right i mean we're
we're in a you know a quarterback you
know what do we want to say sweet spot i
mean the golden age of quarterbacks
really i mean we got a lot of talented
ones in the game right now but mike like
the point you make about brady is that
is there's the point that's exactly like
where i was trying to say see brady had
a support system and an offense and
players that all fit what he did best
and we got to it you know it all got
accentuated to where we got to see the
best of what tom brady can be
and he's fortunate that way and he took
advantage of it i'm not trying to take
anything away from him that way i'm just
saying a lot of quarterbacks don't get
put in that position and yeah you know
you made the thing what happens if if
tom brady's in green bay the last five
six years what does that look like yeah
i would say it doesn't look good and i
would say if you've been around if you
put air i tell my boston friends all the
time i go if aaron rodgers is in new
england you might be going for a 12 pete
right now and that's what i think
it's like 12 in a row they're gonna win
12 in a row like that's where i that yes
so um
we'll see where it goes but you do need
a team around you to show your greatness
and i think mahomes is is another
example of of us seeing that too right
now but you know last thing mike sorry i
don't mean to blabber the nfc afc
conversation i mean that conversation
you talked about the quarterback thing
is very real it really is that's very
interesting and you look at the nfc
and i just wonder you know
man rogers and russell
just have so much on them to make it
happen i know i don't think they're
gonna be able to depend on their
defenses to get them there you know new
orleans is pretty balanced and okay
brady the defense is coming along and
like they they have a chance to be scary
good but man so much is on just rogers
and and russell and okay maybe our
defense will get a stop here and there
and that is going to make things hard
even if they do get to the super bowl
because the afc just seems to have more
complete football teams in my opinion
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports